our shout out tonight for the
investigative reporter at a Minnesota TV
station who with his team broke new
ground the scourge of sex trafficking
and how the state's judges were often
going easy on the men enslaving teenage
girls as prostitutes this investigation
started because we had a Super Bowl here
in Minnesota in 2018 and with that Super
Bowl there was a lot of talk about sex
traffic so our investigative unit really
wanted to go deeper on this subject a
jail ago and his team at kare 11 TV in
Minneapolis st. Paul soon uncovered a
shocking reality that had remained well
and the more we dug into it the more we
started finding reports that Minnesota
here in the middle of the country on
some major highways is in some cases
ground zero for sex trafficking and
passing through going to oilfield proto
or crossing from you know important
Duluth that has big ships coming in
heading down to Chicago and you know
some of your other cities so that must
have been quite a surprise for your
viewers certainly I think it really was
I bet you there was a lot of really our
backyard and a questions that pop up
started exposing and they brought the
story to life with a focus on one
sixteen-year-old girl who they called
Joe Dell this is the police car camera
tape of that young girl being rescued
she and her friend had run away from
home in Duluth and fell into the hands
of two men who began to sell them the
girls were taken to this st. Paul motel
room two to nine is where Joe Dells Hell
began I had a knife put up to my neck
when I was being raped poignant
interviews especially with a young lady
who was willing to share some really
horrific
details of what happened to her and her
experience to showcase why this was such
a problem and how did you get those
incredible police tapes of her and she
was expressing her fear of what was
going on really that took more work than
just about anything else in this
investigation because the police were
understandably loath to release those
eventually ended up working with the
victims and she allowed us to share them
and in some of the other police videos
it was really just identifying key cases
that had you know made headlines across
the state you know in the months and
years prior but hadn't really been
delved into and are really with a really
serious spot but what took this
investigative reporting to a higher
level was what Lego and his team
discovered in area courts once the men
responsible were brought to justice huge
numbers able to avoid what was supposed
to be a mandatory financial fine with
the money used to help victims when we
analyzed seven years of statewide court
data we found from 2011 to 2017 there
were 196 traffickers sentenced but 118
of them 60% had no prostitution
assessment imposed and the more we kept
pulling that string you know initially
we found okay judges aren't imposing
these fines that are supposed to be
mandatory and shortchanging victims of
sex trafficking then we flip it on its
head and we said okay what's happening
with the money when judges actually do
impose and when we did that he found
that the money that was by loss supposed
to be going for very specific things
taking care of things police prosecution
just for training handled these case the
money was missing misplaced misused it
was going into general funds it wasn't
he used the way the law required so we
found that and we kept digging on that
and then we found since okay so we found
money going directly into a pocket is a
bonus getting convictions which was
maybe the most shocking thing we found
and when the kare 11 team sought
reaction from the judges not a single
judge in the state would talk with
including the judge who handled the case
involving 16 year-old Joe tell whose
abusers were convicted but not required
to pay the mandatory fine we email judge
Merrick asking why the failure to find
she refused to be interviewed responding
i do not comment on my cases nor on my
decision-making process it's the kind of
work that does not come easily or
quickly this story took months to
prepare before it ever went on-air we're
juggling other projects at the same time
but I spent weeks just being a records
room reading through cases you know
understanding how sex trafficking cases
work hit our judicial system our unit
has myself but has producer Steve
accurate who I know you know from his
Dateline days what do you say to those
stations that aren't doing this kind of
work with that kind of investment in
backing you need to give your crews time
to do this kind of journalism because
this is what our job is it's the hold
people accountable as to shine a light
in places at you're not going to be able
to in a a and to help end a culture that
has for too long
tolerated cases like that of Joe Dell
[Applause]
and so a well deserved shout out to AJ
and his executive visitor Steve Eckert a
longtime colleague back when I work with
him at NBC News so nice to see him still
have it bringing along a great new
generation of investigative reporters
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week
you